what is going on everybody welcome to
the fourth SQLite tutorial in another
Python 3 basics tutorial in the last
tutorials I showed you guys how you can
create a database create a table insert
to that table and retrieve from that
table and now we're going to be talking
about just showing a real quick example
of like how you might graph from that
table and use matplotlib to show the
data in that table so that's we're going
to do now so let's go ahead and we don't
need to do this read from DB function
anymore and then at the very top of the
script let's go ahead and import
matplotlib dot pi plot as p LT if you
don't have matplotlib and you've never
used it or whatever you can come to
Python programming net here and search
for matplotlib you'll come here and you
can either do there's a huge series here
pretty long tutorial series for you if
you want to learn a lot about matplotlib
but there's also a crash course to
matplotlib here which is actually part
of the Python 3 basics so if you've been
following along that series chances are
you've made it to this point but anyway
if you haven't checked those out and
then pick back up here it's pretty quick
to learn the basics of matplotlib and we
won't be doing anything too advanced
here anyway so import map outlived up PI
plot as PLT and then we're going to
import map plot methylate lib dates as M
dates then we're going to from mat plot
lib import style and then we're going to
a style that you use you put in pretty
much any style you want
I like 538 so we'll use that now of
course you don't have to use style if
you don't want I just think the default
matplotlib graphs are ugly so moving on
we're going to come down here and we're
going to start a new function we call
this define graph underscore data and
um-hmm well let's go back up here so
when we create this date stamp is
creating
from time we may have to revisit we'll
see anyway graph data and though so what
we're going to do is we just want to
graph this information so we're going to
say so what do we want to graph we're
going to graph the value for every type
that is in our database so for example
now I don't want to get too crazy so
we'll just we'll stick with your spy
line
so the fun graph data and we're gonna
say C dot execute and then the query
that we're going to execute here is
going to be a select and we're going to
select date stamp value from stuff to
plot then we're going to have dates
equals an empty list and while values
equals an empty list and one we're just
going to say for row in data what do we
want to do or we say dates dot append
and here's where we want to maybe what
we'll do we can try this one first
matplotlib is really anal about the
types of dates you pass through so what
we're going to do is we're going to pend
unix is going to come through and we're
going to say is for row and data first
let's go ahead and look at the the data
that's going to come through so let's go
UNIX is going to be so for row and data
the UNIX will be row zero so row 0 will
be that UNIX value so we can first let's
print that value and then we're going to
call graph data here paste graph data so
that'll be the UNIX and then what we're
going to do is we're going to take this
we want it to be a date/time object from
timestamp Unix so hopefully this will
work
so say UNIX we pass through row 0 and
let's see if that gives us a date tick
the date/time object or not that should
do it but we're here it is
for Rowan data oh we never defined data
so Rowan C dot fetch all okay so this
should be a date/time object that should
be totally fine so what I'm going to do
is we're going to try to graph that and
then if that gives us a problem there's
another thing we can do but that should
be fine so those that's our date/time
object so actually so what we're going
to do is we're say dates dot append and
we're going to literally append that
date/time object because matplotlib is
going to want date/time and then values
append and we're going to pen row one
then what we're going to do is PLT dot
plot and actually plot date and what we
want to do is we're going to plot dates
values and then that's just the line
style we just want to be aligned that's
all
and then finally PLT dojo in valid
syntax unfortunately i oh you're here no
comma there try again
right okay so there's our graph it's
beautiful there's a little overlap there
but if we make the graph full-size
you'll see that these are just some
timestamps so not the most beautiful
graph by any means uh-huh but there you
go we have a graph and um all that
worked okay so that's just a really
quick basic example how you can select
from a database and graph from a
database including with date data in the
next tutorial what we're going to
talking about is how we can begin to
both change the data that's already
pre-existing in our database sorry for
the skype change the data that's already
existing in our database as well as how
we can delete data that's already in our
database so stay tuned for that if you
have questions comments concerns
whatever in this tutorial please leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
and subscriptions in it till next time